génial lorsqu'elle drôle avec le
handball c'est que ce sont les bleus
possible s'appelle les bleus dans leur
handball comme dans le football qui ont
été champions du monde avant les valeurs
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour votre père
depuis le décès de votre père vous devez
créer un challenge qui s'appelle le
challenge gaston richardson donc et vous
avez dit votre piercing toit avant
d'entrer sur chaque terrain vous le fait
toujours ça jouera toujours s'est enfin
montré très croyant une vanne donner une
éducation pas mince et religieuse alors
moi je dirais c'est une force qui nous
permet justement d'une chaire pas celle
des facultés de vous sentez sa présence
et sa force qui vous êtes informant il
est toujours comment il est parti mais
pour moi il est là pour cesser c'est un
appel que je fais dans les normes dans
les difficultés justement par point
mehdi amar et ma famille pour pouvoir
faire passer bien alors comme tout fait
pour vous refaire une attaque ou
cauchemar en ébauchant
interview cauchemar terrible vous allez
voir c'est terrible on va commencer avec
les accidents conjugaux ce qui serait le
pire pour vous ce serait de vous faire
surprendre par votre femme avec votre
maîtresse de surprendre votre femme avec
votre meilleur pote ou de surprendre
votre femme votre maîtresse en sortir
je pense qu'avec mon pote
ouais alors si vous surprenez vos
chomsky nous c'est terrible pour vous
moi je pense que je je vivrai mal quoi
c'est ueli je sais pas bah ouais
justement je vous fais pas le savoir le
pire cadeau qu'on pourrait vous faire
des vacances avec jean marie bigard un
concert de chants classiques avec
lambert wilson est gay
le concert au contraire que c'est la
pire situation ce serait d'avoir un
pétard mais pas de feu ah oui parce que
la réunion point ça fait l'avion les
annales zaman zama mal zamal si j'y
retourne peu que je me remets nombre à
la tête parce que sinon si je demande 10
pour les gosses anciens qui m'avait
appris ça en fait c'est thierry
jean-pierre le juste de jean-pierre île
de la réunion de zamal il m'avait
expliqué ça alors donc pires situations
un pétard mais pas de feu une carte
bleue mais pas de code ou une fille mais
pas de préservatif une fille c'était ça
serait terrible pour moi je pense pas
sincèrement non il fait plaisir 26
points
ah oui car alors très très très très
préservatif le pire c'est un portable
qui sonne tout le temps un portable qui
sonne jamais jamais jamais et vous
mais on n'a pas d'amis le pire c'est ce
portable lambert wilson bonnes réponses
le pire pour vous ce serait d'être sdf
ou d'habiter dans une maison hantée par
un collant du xviiie siècle alors le
pire ce serait de connaître à l'avancé
le jour de votre mort ou d'ignorer que
vous êtes atteint d'un mal incurable
moi je trouve ça va énerver le 6 mai
rendez-vous ni tous atteints d'un mal
incurable va tous mourir
oui le 200 oui c'est vrai problème et le
ce qui est génial c'est ségo sais pas
quand ouais mais si tu me dis c'est dans
une demi heure j'ai peut-être quitter le
plateau pour aller boire une guerre sans
forcément rester ici le pire ça serait
plus vouloir toucher votre femme ou plus
pouvoir la toucher
je pouvoir le pire vient très timide
le pire c'est de grandir seul de vivre
seul ou de mourir seul
je voudrais mourir seul c'est le pire ça
moi je prends soin moi je crois que j'ai
vraiment plombé la violence l'avant 1g
plomber l'ambiance là comme tout est
déjà là
ouais quand il a la forêt des marais
jackson richardson dont je veux le voir
à bercy
actuellement